who are you I would wake up in the
morning and before I began my day I
would meditate on this and with this
question in mind I kept drawing I
followed the line I let it lead the way
and I drew myself out of a culture that
was only telling me what I couldn't do
the act of giving myself permission to
let go of all fours all fears
insecurities anything that would get in
the way of allowing myself to be
completely me that became my way of
experiencing Freedom over time I began
to create a bold confident space for
myself a space that was all my own
initially it was just my bedroom but
that bedroom ended up in the New York
Times and suddenly I was being seen and
known for this world I had created
drawing has taught me how to create my
own rules
it has taught me to open my eyes and see
not only what is but what can be